Oh
all right let's try d4 game
all right
you
yeah alright let's initiate the exchange
no push up f5
hmm tame
what are we go whoo let's let's
immediately go here and exert pressure
on this point and then put the rook here
so here's the thing this pawn is ill and
if black wants to exchange it I'm
immediately there to make use of this d4
square so I like that just back off
maybe hinting at this fixing the pawn
it's not without its problems
Square Bishop is under fire exchange
let's go here my night might want to go
somewhere other than defending here
against a fork my permanent continues to
fly I could I mean is is black fast to
make use of c4 if I prevent this all
together Alda I don't even know that I I
care that sounded weird I just don't
care I don't know that I care how about
we get a flight Square in there after
all that babbling
fast man is fast and furious
my opponent is fast and furious let's go
here giving up Bishop for Knight like
crazy maybe what am i hoping for strong
night versus a bad Bishop can we just
get a night exchange how do we make this
happen how do we make it happen maybe
like that
let's see you did forward square and I'd
either ducks or says I'm okay if you
initiate the exchange because I take
with the pawn and have another square or
is also saying wait a second if you take
now I have play for my rook
understandable there are weaknesses now
my night eyes one my other one could I
up this square I may think about this
move and only then this if I if I take
now this pawn is backward so maybe I I
go here first and then look for this
maneuver I think I like this idea it's
not without its weaknesses weak weak
weak but it has this point and also this
point I might just grab the knight also
this rook has a responsibility okay
ducks the exchange and I think I'm very
tempted to take the knight and I
probably should now let's just get rid
of that tough guy I'm not concerned
about this being an issue a backward
pawn if they take with pieces because my
King will be a convenient defender I
could devote my King to its defense and
a rook and also you know if they're
putting two rooks on this one point I
put a king and a rook defending and I'll
have one free rook to stir up some
trouble elsewhere meanwhile this Knight
is forever better against the bishop
so decision time it takes like this
maybe check or maybe I don't even care
about the check I'll go somewhere else
should I go on the kingside
mmm-hmm no no I must feel like I want to
just stick around here maybe this maybe
this if the Queen tries to do something
exciting
I've set the Queen I want I want a queen
exchange I think I always want to keep
one rook on board until it maybe gets to
a point where my King is really well
positioned and I could exchange rooks
and be assured my king is active enough
so what's a good approach here can I go
with something as simple as rook up and
then shoot for the c7 square destination
rank bishop there let's control the
bishop this rook has a responsibility I
can I'm pretty confident that it does
not like having to babysit this pawn so
this is one of the the benefits of the
knight being on d4 ties down one of the
black pieces and cannot be removed I
should have considered that this was a
possibility but some I don't want to
touch my Jeep on just yet I don't think
my Queen will mind recapturing okay
Queen is massive piece right now okay
okay Queen exchange I have anything
better I'm gonna say let's just take and
make sure this pawn doesn't look to
break down here and I don't want to see
this bishop ever come to life along this
diagonal so they're gonna pinpoint this
square it seems so let's step up
who go here and I'm using the same
reasoning if they you know try and put
two rooks on this one point I just have
a king and a rook and a free rook to
play with pressure on this point now I
want one rook exchange also another
benefit with this Knight is even if they
gain control over the C file it prevents
the rook C to move so I'm getting one
rook off still down on the clock forty
seconds I guess we can keep the tension
does it really matter I don't know we'll
just exchange get active and again not
be afraid of this stuff okay I'm just
going to keep it locked
also now this my knight should not be
afraid to go elsewhere let's
Oh oh no no no let's go here let's just
hit the bishop I have a check okay check
now oh they're dropping the bishop okay
and now we just want to trade Brooks
that's all we want to do
also oh if I want to trade rooks why am
I not going here I don't know
make sure there's no pawn breaks you
know
control you guys maybe hearing some
fireworks soon yeah yeah oh yeah big
time there's there's a lot of fireworks
going on it is not the 4th of July but
you know the weekend is still still
around so fireworks are nearby ok they
resigned
all right another technical game
you